hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live letzte Nacht mitten in der Nacht
bebt die Erde in der Türkei und in
Syrien ein Beben wohl der Stärke von 7,8
reist die Menschen aus dem Schlaf ein
Mitarbeiter der Hilfsorganisation wird
Vision aus Syrien beschreibt während wir
schliefen begann das Haus zu zittern ich
rannte sofort zu meinen Kindern konnte
aber nicht alle tragen ich konnte die
Tür nicht erreichen die Entfernung war
zu weit eine Minute kam mir vor wie eine
Endlosigkeit
mindestens 1.400 Menschen sollen ums
Leben gekommen sein es gibt unendlich
viele Verletzte aber die Zahlen könnten
wohl auch noch weiter steigen denn viele
gelten noch immer als verschüttet es ist
das stärkste Erdbeben in der Region seit
Jahrzehnten und dabei blieb es nicht es
gab weitere starke Nachbeben und vor
einer Stunde auch wieder eine Meldung
über ein erneutes Beben wohl der Stärke
von 7,5 wir können uns das ganze mal auf
einer Karte anschauen wo sich das ganze
ereignet hat und zwar das Epizentrum des
Bebens das lag in der türkischen Provinz
caraman Marash jetzt sehen wir es auch
im Südosten ganz in der Nähe der
syrischen Grenze bis nach Homs in Syrien
gab es heftigste Erschütterungen und
eben ein weiteres Beben der Stärke 6,6
gab es in der Nacht kurz danach noch in
der türkischen Stadt Gaziantep endliche
etliche Häuser stürzten ein und in
dieser Sendung sprechen wir mit Augen
mit einer Augenzeuge Zeugin mit der
Koordinatorin der Hilfe vor Ort und mit
dem Geo
forschungsforschungszentrum
Entschuldigung in Potsdam ihr könnt
Fragen stellen direkt im Stream oder
auch per Mail mit kommentieren und
zuerst könnt ihr jetzt fragen stellen
live in die Türkei an unsere Reporterin
vor Ort an eine Brühe hallo Anne die
Lage ganz aktuell hallo Lage ganz
aktuell vor einer Stunde gab es ja
wieder eine Meldung über ein Beben in
der Region was weißt du dazu was weißt
du mehr
ja wieder ist caraman Marash betroffen
7,5 stark war dieses Beben es ist eines
von unendlich vielen dieser Nachbeben
insgesamt 100 gibt es und die erschweren
natürlich die
Rettungsmaßnahmen die Menschen werden
natürlich aufgefordert ihre Häuser
sollten Sie noch stehen zu verlassen
dieses Nachbeben in Karaman Maras hat
auch dafür gesorgt dass neue Häuser
eingestürzt sind also es ist wichtig
dass die Menschen sich in Sicherheit
bringen und sie tun das bei Temperaturen
die in der Region auch nur um den
Gefrierpunkt liegen es schneit es regnet
und auch das erschwert natürlich die
Rettungsmaßnahmen man muss sagen wir
sehen ja immer wieder diese Bilder wo wo
die Menschen einfach angefangen haben
mit bloßen Händen nach Leuten zu graben
die lokalen rettungskräfte sind
natürlich vor Ort und und und retten es
ist das Polizei ist dabei das türkische
Militär auch der Rote Halbmond aus der
ganzen Türkei werden jetzt auch
weitere Rettungskräfte zusammengezogen
die Flüge in die Region sind alle
reserviert für Hilfskräfte aber auch die
Autobahn zum Beispiel ist durch die
Schneesituation
da gibt es keinen durchkommen in der
Stadt malatia ist das Dach des
Flughafens eingestürzt also auch da ist
es schwer Hilfe hinzubekommen und
insgesamt ist das ja ein riesiges Gebiet
10 Provinzen alleine in der Türkei sind
betroffen das zieht sich bis in den
Osten nach diabakir wir haben die Bilder
auch gerade neben dir gesehen unfassbar
also einstürzende Häuser die Menschen du
sagst das versuchen sich in ja versuchen
sich irgendwie in Sicherheit zu bringen
da bleibt im Zweifel nur draußen die
offene Straße wir haben direkt auf
fragen wir uns im Stream von MSE bei
Youtube er oder sie möchte wissen wie
wird denn den Menschen geholfen
das toxische Militär hat tatsächlich
schon eine Luftbrücke eingerichtet da
werden jetzt Hilfsgüter in die Region
geflogen auch hier in Istanbul wird das
koordiniert das heißt da geht es jetzt
darum war mit Decken Kleidung Zelte
Wasser zu bringen
wahrscheinlich werden auch Zeltstädte
errichtet werden weil die Menschen die
ihre Häuser verloren haben müssen ja
auch irgendwo untergebracht werden wie
gesagt es herrschen Minusgrade in oder
oder die die die Temperaturen sind um
den Gefrierpunkt das ist also sehr kalt
und die Menschen müssen da jetzt erstmal
in Sicherheit gebracht werden sie sind
von den Behörden auch aufgefordert
worden zum Beispiel ihre Mobiltelefone
nicht zu benutzen was erstmal ein
bisschen abstrus klingt weil viele
natürlich ihren liebsten irgendwo anders
im Land bescheid sagen wollen dass sie
ihn Sicherheit sind aber sie sind
aufgefordert worden nämlich zu
telefonieren die Leitungen freizuhalten
weil er die Rettungskräfte sich ja
hoffen über Handy dann eben auch mit
verschütteten weiter Kontakt aufnehmen
zu können
aktuelle Eindrücke von Anne Brühl aus
der Türkei vielen Dank
und die Ereignisse in der letzten Nacht
über diese mehreren Beben anna hat das
angesprochen an die 100 sollen es
gewesen sein mit Nachbeben dazu gezählt
immer dieser Ereignisse schauen wir
jetzt erst zusammen noch einen Bericht
von Oliver Flamm
nur Sekunden bleiben ihnen zur Flucht
ein Mann schreit versucht zu warnen dann
bricht das Gebäude zusammen niemand weiß
wie viele Menschen allein hier in
schanhofer unter den Trümmern begraben
werden
die meisten wurden von dem grauen im
Schlaf überrascht in den frühen
Morgenstunden das stärkste Beben seit
Jahrzehnten heißt es allein in der
Türkei sind mehr als 1.700 Gebäude
eingestürzt um die Toten kann sich kaum
jemand kümmern die Zeit drängt nach
Überlebenden zu suchen bei Temperaturen
um den Gefrierpunkt ein Wettlauf gegen
die Zeit
die Erde hat in einem sehr großen Gebiet
gebebt insgesamt zehn Städte sind
betroffen wir haben außerdem strengen
Winter wir versuchen alles um so schnell
wie möglich Hilfe zu den Menschen zu
bringen
auch im benachbarten Syrien verursacht
das Beben in mehreren Provinzen
schwerste Zerstörungen Hilfe ist
angelaufen immer wieder begeben sich die
Retter selbst in Lebensgefahr doch
überall können sie nicht sein
darunter liegen 12 Familien keiner hat
es raus geschafft sie sind alle noch
drin noch war niemand hier um zu schauen
wie es den Menschen geht kein
Zivilschutz wir graben mit unseren
Händen seit 3 Uhr morgens
auch in japak hier in der Türkei geht
die Suche nach Überlebenden und
Vermissten weiter viele wissen nicht ob
ihre Angehörigen ist noch rechtzeitig
raus geschafft haben als mitten in der
Nacht die Erde zu beben begann unter den
Trümmern dieses Hochhauses werden noch
viele Opfer befürchtet es könnten
hunderte sein
in japakira hat die Vorsitzende der
Linken Janine Wissler die jetzt bei uns
ist das Erdbeben selbst miterlebt sie
war dort letzte Nacht was haben sie
erlebt schönen guten Tag Frau Wissler
guten Tag ja ich bin viert aus dem
schlafgerissen worden weil alles
gewackelt hat weil es ja furchtbare
Geräusche gab und das war wirklich ein
heftiges Beben und das war vor allem
sehr lange andauernd also
ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt
wann hört das auf und dann geht das zu
Ende weil man sich auch so hilflos fühlt
und gar nicht weiß wo man hin soll wenn
unter einem der Boden lebt und dann bin
ich nach den Nachbarn raus auf die
Straße gegangen und habe überall
verzweifelte weinende Menschen getroffen
Menschen die zum Teil wirklich barfuß
nur mit Sandalen aus dem Haus gerannt
sind bei Minustemperaturen um ihr Leben
zu retten und hat natürlich auch die
eingestürzten Gebäude gesehen und die
große Ausmaß der Verwüstung und da sind
ganze Wohngebäude zusammengestürzt
mehrstöckige und die Vorstellung und das
dar zwei Menschen verschüttet sind und
jetzt immer noch auf Hilfe warten das
ist furchtbar sie sind selbst jetzt
gerade in Ankara wie haben wir uns das
vorzustellen also die Straßen die sind
befahrbar sie konnten Ausfliegen wie hat
das funktioniert
das hat funktioniert es gab einzelne
Straßensperrungen heute Morgen und es
gab eben also wenn man durch die Stadt
fährt dann sieht man eben die das Ausmaß
der Zerstörung eingestürzte Häuser und
aber man konnte jetzt die Stadt
verlassen wobei man jetzt ja sagen muss
dass das jetzt auch nicht das Epizentrum
ist also es gibt ja noch Regionen die
noch deutlich schwerer betroffen sind in
Nordsyrien in der Südtürkei die noch
schwerer betroffen sind und wo es
überhaupt keinen Überblick darüber gibt
wie viele Menschen dort eigentlich noch
vermisst werden und wie viele Menschen
verschüttet sind und wahrscheinlich ich
weiß nicht ob sie sowas schon mal erlebt
haben aber wussten Sie überhaupt auch in
dem Moment was es zu tun das heißt ja
immer man soll die Gebäude verlassen
kann man nämlich in dem Moment überhaupt
klar denken wie ist das
ich war schon klar das ist ein Erdbeben
ist weil natürlich die Türkei ist ein in
der Erdbeere im Regionen gefährdete
Region was mich aber wirklich auch
überrascht hat ist dann auf die Straße
zu gehen und mit den Menschen zu reden
und diese Angst zu erleben weil ich bin
ja selber auch mit einer Abgeordneten
des türkischen Parlaments hier unterwegs
von der HDP die in der Türkei lebt die
Erdbeben häufig erlebt hat und wie
gesagt hat so ein schweres Leben hat sie
noch nie erlebt in dieser Heftigkeit in
dieser Länge das heißt also ich konnte
es aber einfach nicht einordnen ich habe
mich
sehr sehr beängstigend ich konnte nicht
einordnen wie schwer das Leben ist
anfangs aber die mit meinem pleiterin
und Begleiter haben eben auch gesagt
dass sie so etwas nie erlebt haben und
ja man fühlt sich einfach total hilflos
wenn man gar nicht genau weiß wo soll
man hin wenn einem unter einem die Erde
gibt und jetzt war es so dass an dem
Hotel nämlich war gab es nur ganz
leichte Beschädigungen also uns ist
nichts passiert aber wenn man das
ausmacht der Zerstörung sieht und sich
vor Augen hält das hier hunder nicht
möglicherweise tausende Menschen
gestorben sind es ist furchtbar und wir
brauchen es braucht ganz schnell jetzt
humanitäre Hilfe internationale Hilfe
weil das ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
die Temperaturen sind niedrig es ist
Schnee angesagt und es liegt auch Schnee
in tja bei Kia und in den Gebieten also
von daher ist es jetzt ein Wettlauf
gegen die Zeit so viel wie möglich
Menschen jetzt noch Leben zu retten zum
Schluss noch die Frage das was sie dann
heute morgen auch erlebt haben kam die
Hilfe denn durch also das funktioniert
schon oder waren war das auch so wie wir
es im Beitrag gesehen haben einfach
viele Menschen die mit bloßen Händen da
jetzt graben müssen weil es eben fehlt
an Hilfsgütern an ja Gerät zum Aufräumen
also heute Nacht war es auf jeden Fall
so dass das doch sehr chaotisch war dass
dann eben meine Abgeordneten Kollegin
aus der Türkei die wo bei ihr zu Hause
um die Ecke ein Wohnhaus eingestürzt ist
die wirklich versucht hat mit anderen
mit bloßen Händen Menschen da aus den
Trümmern zu befreien was ihr nicht
gelungen ist weil man dafür natürlich
einfach schweres Gerät braucht das aber
nicht kam also von daher ich kann das
jetzt aktuell in der Situation nicht
beurteilen aber ich denke schon dass
gerade auch in den abgelegenen Gebieten
und gerade auch in den syrischen
Gebieten es dringend notwendig ist dass
es dort auch ja Hilfe von außen gibt
weil gerade in Syrien da sind auch die
großen flüchtlingskamps betroffen was
man hört Teile von Nordost Syrien sind
zerstört durch die türkischen Angriffe
im letzten November da war sowieso auch
die strominfrastruktur zusammengebrochen
und da ist es dringend notwendig eben
jetzt zu helfen wie das genau
funktioniert kann ich jetzt aktuell
nicht beurteilen aber ich denke es
braucht dringend internation Solidarität
und unterstützen sagt Janine Wissler
Vorsitzende der Linken die das Erdbeben
live miterlebt hat vielen Dank Frau
Wissler
und genau wie das funktioniert die
Koordination der Hilfe und wie das auch
in den nächsten Tagen weiter
funktionieren wird darüber können wir
jetzt sprechen mit der
diakoniekatastrophenhilfe mit Wilke
sie koordiniert die Hilfe vor Ort für
die Türkei und für Syrien wir erreichen
Sie in Jordanien hallo schönen guten Tag
guten Tag es ist viel internationale
Hilfe zugesagt worden also auch von
Deutschland die EU schickt Rettungsteams
wie ist das Ganze aber zu koordinieren
jetzt das sind ja zwei Länder betroffen
große Bereiche eine riesen Region unter
schwierigsten Bedingungen ja auch
betroffen die lässt sich das jetzt am
besten koordinieren dass die Hilfe
schnell ankommt
genau also als diakoniekatastrophenhilfe
sind wir seit
2012 bereits in der Türkei tätig und
zwar im Rahmen unserer serial response
die betroffenen Provinzen insbesondere
die zehn Provinzen die wir gerade
betroffen sind sind vielleicht manchen
humanitären Akteuren auch schon bekannt
denn gerade in diesen Provinzen leben
auch viele geflüchtete das heißt der
humanitäre Bedarf war bislang auch schon
da im Moment ist es so dass wir zwei
Nothilfe Teams bzw zwei nothilfe-teams
unseres Partners von Easter nach Hatay
geschickt haben sie werden sich vor Ort
ein genaues Bild machen über den Bedarf
über die Bedarfe die natürlich in den
nächsten Stunden noch weiterhin steigen
werden und basierend darauf würden wir
dann auch
unsere response und Nothilfe dann
starten wir haben Fragen aus unserer
Community auch gerade was die Hilfe
anbelangt zwar fragt sich Web Neo bei
Youtube wie viele Menschen sind denn
insgesamt in der Region betroffen von
dem Erdbeben lässt sich das jetzt so
einfach sagen
das ist sehr schwierig wie sie vorhin
schon gesagt haben ist vor ca einer
Stunde ein weiteres Erdbeben leider
festgestellt also wurde ein weiteres
Erdbeben gespürt auch mit einer Stärke
von 7,5 glaube ich das heißt der Bedarf
wird weiterhin schreiben und wir müssen
leider von mehreren Tausenden von
Todesopfern leider ausgehen hinzu kommt
das natürlich mehrere Häuser eingestürzt
sind oder beschädigt sind und was zu
Beton ist ist natürlich die Jahreszeit
gerade jetzt im Winter wird es besonders
schwierig sein für die Menschen die nun
ihr zu Hause verloren haben ich hatte
vorhin mal kurz geschaut da sie andere
ist z.B eines der betroffenen Provinzen
das Wetter ist sehr kalt dort äh ca 3
Grad und dementsprechend wird auch
unsere response auch aussehen wie gesagt
wir warten noch auf die genaueren
Ergebnisse des ähm das fällt Teams dass
sich auf dem Weg befindet und dem
entsprechend da kann man auch jetzt
schon davon ausgehen dass winterartikel
verteilt werden müssen das Zelte
verteilt werden müssen Hygieneartikeln
werden mit Sicherheit auch relevant sein
aber auch beispielsweise mobile Latrinen
eben auch Nordsyrien ist betroffen eine
Region in der sowieso besonders viele
geflüchtete Leben unter sowieso schon
schwierigen Bedingungen was brauchen sie
denn jetzt am meisten
ja auch in Syrien ist es so wir haben
als DkH sowohl für die Türkei und für
Syrien unser Programm vor wir sehen das
heißt wir werden in Bayern bei den
Ländern aus Eigenmitteln und unsere
Nothilfe unser nothilfeprogramm starten
in Syrien ist es natürlich so dass die
humanitäre Lage dort noch
gravierender leider ist wahr und
zuzüglich des das Erdbebens werden sich
auch dort die Bedarfe weiterhin
verschärfen und auch dort wird es
weiterhin sehr wahrscheinlich so
aussehen dass insbesondere wegen der
aktuellen Jahreszeit und der Kälte viele
Menschen auch Zelte und Decken und
Winter Artikel angewiesen sein werden
und wie gefährlich ist das wenn denn
jetzt die Menschen wieder zurück in ihre
Häuser kehren sofern sie es denn können
denn wir haben ja jetzt auch schon
drüber gesprochen von einer Stunde also
ein erneutes beben
also im Moment ist es so dass unser das
Mitarbeitende unseres lokalen Partners
auch noch nicht in ihre Häuser
zurückgekehrt sind es ist auch sogar
noch so dass wir auch noch nicht leider
noch nicht alle erreichen konnten in der
Provinz hat halt beispielsweise das sehr
stark vom Leben vom Erdbeben betroffen
ist ist leider ähm die Telekommunikation
gerade sehr schwierig deshalb wir wissen
auch noch nicht wo alle unsere
Mitarbeitende sind aber auch
Mitarbeitende wie zum Beispiel in der
Provinzial oder auch in anderen
Provinzen konnten bislang noch nicht
zurückkehren das heißt Sie müssen
draußen in der Kälte übernachten
und wenn wir jetzt auch noch mal über
die spezielle Lage in Nordsyrien
sprechen ist es denn da überhaupt
möglich auch in alle verschiedenen
Gebiete vorzudringen mit der Hilfe
das kommt natürlich auch ein Stück weit
auf die örtlichen
koordinierungsmechanismen an ähnlich wie
in der Türkei als auch in Syrien ist es
in solchen Situationen sehr wichtig dass
bestimmte koordinierungsmechanismen
funktionieren ob und wie das in Syrien
passieren wird das werden wir in den
nächsten Tagen feststellen klar wir
haben wie gesagt unser assessment-team
sozusagen aus Istanbul sofort in die
Region geschickt aber so einfach ist das
natürlich in Syrien nicht
und kann man abschätzen überhaupt in
welcher Region aktuell die Hilfe am
meisten gebraucht wird oder sind es
mehrere wie würden sie das Einschätzen
also im Moment wie gesagt gehen wir
davon aus dass es zehn Provinzen im
Südosten der Türkei sind die sehr stark
vom Erdbeben betroffen sind und wie
gesagt sind das auch insbesondere
Provinzen in denen der humanitäre Bedarf
bislang auch sehr groß war unter anderem
wegen den geflüchteten aus Syrien aus
dem Irak in der letzten Zeit auch in den
letzten Monaten auch aus Afghanistan das
Land befindet sich zudem in einer
Wirtschaftskrise auch das wird sich mit
Sicherheit leider jetzt spürbar machen
sagt Bilge mir nächste von der Diakonie
Katastrophenhilfe vielen Dank dass Sie
bei uns zu Gast waren ich danke Ihnen
gerne
und wir können jetzt sprechen über noch
weitere ja noch weitere Erdbeben oder
grundsätzlich das was passiert ist über
die Beben und die Nachbeben was da noch
zu erwarten ist mit der Professorin
Charlotte Kraft schick vom deutschen Geo
Forschungszentrum in Potsdam schönen
guten Tag
guten Tag ich grüße sie jetzt haben wir
gehört es gab also noch ein weiteres
Beben es gab das große Beben in der
Nacht mit etlichen Nachbeben dann ist es
dann vorbei
aber in der Nacht ging es definitiv los
und die anatolische und arabische Platte
haben sich nicht nur aneinander vorbei
bewegt wie sieht es immer machen und was
wir kennen sondern sie haben auch ein
sehr starkes Erdbeben ausgelöst die
Nachläufer dauern den ganzen Tag über an
und wie beobachten das auch genau mit
dem geophunden-netzwerk im
Geoforschungszentrum Potsdam und wir
können feststellen dass es auch noch
starke Beben gibt die in der Sequenz als
Nachläufer durchlaufen das heißt die
Region ist noch nicht zur Ruhe gekommen
genau vielleicht erklären Sie uns das
noch mal wie kommen die wirklich genau
zustande sie haben eben diese Platten
angesprochen also warum passiert das
ja geodynamisch liegt dieser Bereich der
Türkei in dem Gebiet wo wir verschiedene
tektonische Platten haben die sich
bewegen und auch gegeneinander bewegen
in diesem Fall jetzt an der anatomischen
Störungszone haben wir die arabische
Platte und die anatolische Platte die
bewegen sich horizontal aneinander
vorbei
angenommen die würden sich einfach ganz
glatt ohne Reibung aneinander vorbei
bewegen wird nichts passieren aber es
ist natürlich ähm Gebirge Gelände alles
vorhanden und dadurch gibt es Reibungen
und ab und zu verhaken sich auch
einzelne Teilbereiche von diesen Platten
wenn sie sich verhaken wird also die
Bewegung nicht abgebaut sondern es baut
sich Spannung auf und die entleert sich
so wie wir das jetzt sehen in einem sehr
starken Ereignis und ist diese Region
dann auch besonders gefährdet auch für
die Zukunft dass das wieder passiert
dass dort Erdbeben stattfinden das ist
bekannt also auch das letzte Mal vor
allerdings 1000 Jahren etwa in dieser
Zone gab es auch historisch überliefert
sehr starke Erdbeben das heißt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer gegeben
dass dort Erdbeben zum einen auch
kleinerer Magnitude auftreten aber das
auch ab und an sagen wir mal im Rhythmus
von normalerweise 100 bis 200 Jahren
große Ereignisse auftreten insofern
bedeutet das wenn jetzt tausend Jahre
dort kein großes Ereignis war das ist in
dem Sinne für die Wissenschaft
überfällig gewesen ist dass es dort zu
einem großen Ereignis auch tatsächlich
kommt
die erste Meldung die wir hatten über
das große Beben das erste mitten in der
Nacht da hieß es das sei ein Beben der
Stärke 7,4 gewesen jetzt haben wir von
ihnen eben auch in Potsdam gehört es
handelt sich um ein bebende Stärke 7,8
die so gab es da unterschiedliche
Angaben zunächst
die Daten laufen sozusagen automatisiert
ein mittlerweile in den internationalen
Netzwerken werden dann aber gerade wenn
solche heftigen Ereignisse passieren
auch noch mal manuell ausgewertet und
angeschaut auch bezüglich dessen was wir
dann so als wissenschaftliches Interesse
haben um zum Beispiel die Ausbreitung
der Energie im Untergrund anzuschauen
und dort wurde sozusagen noch mal Hand
angelegt und die Magnitude dann
entsprechend auch korrigiert mit vor
allen Dingen auch noch mehr
Messstationen die dann abgesicherte
Daten geliefert haben
wir haben eine Frage bei uns im Stream
von User Alexander der möchte wissen wie
sieht es denn mit Frühwarnsystem für
Erdbeben aus
in der Türkei gibt es Frühwarnsysteme
die beschränken sich aber derzeit auf
den Bereich der marmarer See überall
anders gibt es auch seismische
seismologische Überwachung das heißt man
beobachtet die bodenunruhe und
insbesondere auch vor Ort der
Katastrophenschutz ist sehr aktiv um die
kritischen Bereiche in der
Landesaufnahme auch tatsächlich zu
überwachen
und noch eine Frage von jemand der sich
Peter Pan nennt und zwar könnten die
Nachbeben also die noch kommen noch
stärker sein als die bisherigen
dazu kann man leider wirklich keine
Aussage machen was wir bisher gesehen
haben ist dass es nach dem großen leben
heute Nacht kleinere Beben gab und dass
es sich jetzt aber noch mal zu einem
großen Beben kriminiert hat ob es so
weitergeht oder wann das ganze System
zur Ruhe kommt können wir nicht wirklich
im Moment schon Vorhersagen dafür ist
das alles noch viel zu frisch und eben
auch nicht wie viele weitere Beben noch
kommen könnten da hat man keine
Erfahrungswerte das ist sehr willkürlich
oder wie können wir uns das vorstellen
das ist ganz spezifisch immer abhängig
davon wie viele Beben Auftreten in
welchen Bereich es ist wie viel schon
sozusagen an Bruchfläche aufgerissen ist
und wie sich dann die Platten weiter
danach verhalten also das können wir
jetzt ohne weitere Daten oder Messung
können wir da keine Angabe zu machen
danke für Ihre Einschätzung dass sie
sich so viel Zeit für unsere Fragen
genommen haben Professor Charlotte
Krawczyk vom deutschen
Geoforschungszentrum in Potsdam vielen
Dank
gerne
und ich habe gesehen dass viele von euch
dass ihr euch fragt wie ihr auch helfen
könnt wie wir von Deutschland aus helfen
können ich versuche gerade gebt mir
einen kleinen Moment mal kurz für euch
unsere Spendentafel die wenn nämlich
eingerichtet haben zu zeigen dann
könnten wir die kurz auf meinem
Bildschirm zeigen ich habe sie jetzt
gerade nur in einer kleineren Version
aber es geht ja um die Info die drauf
steht das ist ja das Wichtigste und zwar
gibt es einen Spendenaufruf vom
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe da
könntet ihr wenn ihr möchtet eben auch
Spenden ein Spendenkonto ist
eingerichtet die IBAN
de65100 400
600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien das hatten einige gefragt
das wollte ich euch gerne zeigen und
haben sich eben auch gefragt ob einfach
Hilfe aus Deutschland kommt ja die kommt
das die wurde zugesagt das hatte
Bundeskanzler Scholz getwittert und es
gibt an so einem schrecklichen Tag wo
die Zahl der Toten inzwischen auf 1.500
gesprungen ist und wie gesagt auch noch
mehr Tote befürchtet werden und
verletzte weil es eben so viele
verschüttete noch gibt gibt es aber
natürlich auch immer kleine Momente der
Hoffnung und so einen wollen wir euch
jetzt gerne zeigen denn immer wieder
werden auch Menschen gerettet wie jetzt
hier in Ersatz in Syrien dort konnte
tatsächlich ein Kind gerettet werden und
wird hier aus den Trümmern gezogen also
bleibt sie die Hoffnung natürlich dass
auch noch Menschen unter diesen Trümmern
gefunden werden wir berichten für euch
weiter den ganzen Tag und auch heute bei
ZDF Spezial im Fernsehen gibt es bei uns
um 19:20 Uhr eine Sondersendung schaut
da auch gerne vorbei wenn ihr möchtet
bis hierhin jetzt erstmal danke für eure
Aufmerksamkeit und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss